let's do this let's jump over to uh the
hypocrisy
because i really wanna i really wanna
highlight this and we're gonna call out
um
a high-profile activist i hate calling
out people
specifically yeah i agree but what we're
dealing with
right now let me just tell you a man in
austin wielding a rifle
walks up to a car gets shot and killed
some witnesses said he pointed it at the
vehicle
after the guy shot him shot this uh the
driver shoots the guy with the gun
someone else approach one of these i
guess rioters at this point
started shooting the dude's vehicle he
fled the cops arrested these two guys
this man garrett who had the rifle died
so again we have a photo of him holding
the gun
and witnesses said he pointed at the
vehicle and then got shot so so just a
little context too
um i saw that i saw a couple different
eyewitness videos of this
now they were they were marching
straight they were kind of all
spread out the i'm talking about the
protesters
and this car was just driving down the
street
it kind of like reached where the crowd
was and honked a few times
it like bumped a barrier kind of like no
there was no barrier no barrier
it honked a couple times like you know
get out of the way
and you can see all of them were like
finally we can like take like our anger
at someone they all turned and
just converged on the car and anyone
within like a 30
foot radius turned and like came to the
car
so like imagine you know what that would
feel like if you're in that car
surrounded by people they're all yelling
and you look out the window and what do
you see
someone brandishing an ak-47 it is an ak
that's what yeah
that's what it was so i'm just giving a
little context to
what happened previous before you know
the actual incident
then bang bang bang bang bang five shots
five shots followed by three shots
according to law enforcement those three
shots with someone from the protest
shooting at the car
this guy garrett died a gofundme was
launched
the gofundme has raised over let me see
if i can pull it up
a hundred and seven thousand dollars
eight hundred and twenty four and they
just
they disabled it i was wondering why
gofundme allowed this
and not a bunch of other gofundmes that
get deleted or taken down
good question if this guy really did
point that rifle
and he may have we have video of him
actually having his hand on the grip
if he succeeded in causing harm or
threatening someone's life this would
have been taken down in two seconds
only because his life was taken i
suppose they're allowing it
but what do you think the left is
referring to him as martyr
of course a martyr of the cause you know
why because the far left recognizes
their right
to the second amendment their right to
walk around with loaded guns
but not yours because when it comes to
the couple in saint louis
kim gardner seeks to stop missouri
attorney general from meddling in
mccloskey gun case that's right
you know that's that's rich when they
were meddling with the
the evidence themselves right now we did
a full
subject on this you can you can check
our past videos and we we did a full
segment run down on that that so you can
check that out
so here so well basically the context
when
patricia mccloskey she had a handgun it
was inoperable because the firing pin
and spring were reversed
they claimed that was intentional
because they were using it as a prop in
a courtroom
they apparently when it was delivered to
the crime lab
they disassembled it it was inoperable
so they disassembled it and reassembled
it and then said
it was readily available you know
readily capable of federal
of lethal force now the left has argued
because i've talked to some leftists
about this
they said the crime lab was just trying
to see if the weapon
could work they weren't tampering with
evidence
and i think that is a total cop-out
absolutely
they're saying no the mccloskeys flipped
the pin after the fact to make it seem
like it and i'm like
that's conjecture you got no proof that
happened all we know is the weapon they
received was inoperable
and and it was changed from when it
entered evidence to
now right that's tampering that that is
tampering at with evidence
period i mean that their attorney said
so but the media is not saying it
there's been no charges or anything in
the media
okay right sure
well so here's the bigger picture man
here's the big picture how is it
that regular if if you are a regular
person
on your property and a mob of people
enter your private property and use
legally say
get off my property you're a villain
you're a villain
and how is it if you're this guy in
austin with an ak and you walk up
someone's car
they say you're a martyr i'm now going
to show you some facebook posts from
someone
i normally don't like to highlight but
it needs to be done because this guy's
got millions of followers
and as much as many people really really
hate him especially progressives they
really don't like him yeah
he's one of the most prominent and
well-known black lives matter activists
all right where's this this awful image
sean king
here's what sean king said that's
garrett foster
he was an unarmed unarmed non-violent
demonstrator last night in austin texas
well
i got to stop right there i'm sorry i
got to stop right there let me let me
just play a game with y'all let me let
me play a game of
showing you a photograph of garrett
foster holding his ak
okay approaching this is this is the
video where he's actually approaching
the the vehicle you can see it right
here he he's clearly
you know he's holding the grip he's got
the grip and and
like the look in his eye is like i'm
coming i'm coming at this this person
it's as far as i'm seeing right now it's
aimed down you can see this the stock up
in the air
he's looking forward he's armed he's
armed that's all that matters he's armed
yeah absolutely so so why there's a
video no not only
is he armed there's a video of him
talking about how
he is proudly walking around exercising
his 2a rights
yep with his and talking about what what
the gun is it's like and how he's
people proudly talking about being armed
and he basically says those who oppose
us won't do anything about it
that's true he doesn't and then he goes
up to this car look what are they doing
on this car
what are they doing in this guy's car
why are they surrounding it wearing
masks yeah that's what i was saying
it they really just everyone in that
that circle around the car
turned and just approached the vehicle
right to clarify the max masks
i get it ross was wearing masks of covid
the point is
the driver doesn't know it doesn't
matter a bunch of masked individuals
running and yelling at the car you do
with a rifle
armed what did sean king say unarmed
non-violent demonstrator in austin
and was shot and killed protesting for
black lives matter with his fiance
whitney
a man tried to run protesters over with
a car
wasn't even moving then fired eight
shots at them
not even true in the slightest oh my
gosh it keeps killing gears
worse and worse who was pushing whitney
in a wheelchair
i'm sorry is he pushing somebody in a
wheelchair in that picture both hands on
the gun like maybe maybe
is maybe that's not really good maybe
he's just lifting the wheelchair up like
this no and i i saw the video
the car clearly comes to a stop then
honks
and then they all mob his car you want
you want you want to drive
do you want to hit the nail on the head
with a hammer right now good go ahead
drive let's drive it
let's drive it home here's the final
portion of sean king's post
we're working hard in all 50 states and
need your help volunteer and
donate now at grassrootslaw.org okay
yep monetizing emotions that's all i'm
seeing right now
yep yep monetizing posting fake news and
you know what
that's his that's what he does that's he
probably look at this
120 128
000 likes 51 000 000
shares people get emotional they get
emotionally triggered when they see that
didn't he uh falsely accuse a cop of
sexual assault
i don't remember that yeah can you pull
that paper you pull it up
yeah it was like a big thing where he
published this big fake news i believe
we'll get
the source on it but let me what do you
think mr king had to say about the
mccloskeys
certainly he would argue they're martyrs
as well i'm sure
for this cause in innocent you know uh
dwellers of their own homes
holding rifles the same sure certainly
they were oh wait i'm sorry
wait wait what what's up here's what he
says this st
louis and the armed people you see here
are market patrice mccloskey attorneys
who did this when protesters walked past
their house on their way to protest the
mayor
protesters weren't even there for them
not a single person threatened them they
pulled out an ar-15 assault rifle and a
pistol and began aiming
at men women and children oh my goodness
it violates missouri criminal code
57103014
which says citizens are not allowed to
exhibit any weapon capable of lethal use
in an angry or threatening matter now
this one only got 15 000
shares 22 000 likes but
the point is when it comes to their side
they're the heroes when it comes to
anyone else
they're the villains i think it's a
story it's a story they treat it like a
story
oh did you find the source about well
i'm seeing here that sean king used to
work for the intercept which makes me
kind of sad
yep and i'm seeing that he's being
slammed for pushing a woman's now
discredited accusation
she accused daniel hubbard of assault
and he was wrong um it says sean king
was
being slammed for pushing a woman's now
discredited claim that a trooper
assaulted her
this is from i would say 2018. yeah so
he's
there you go yeah so he's just lying
he's just another storytelling media
personality that's all they are all
these storytellers
yeah you know we got we gotta come up we
gotta come up with the name not not
grifter because that can be applied to
anyone
but there's there's gotta be a name for
reporters
you know these personalities that report
news that is
that i mean yeah that that's fake it's
like john oliver used to i used to think
he was funny
i used to think it was so funny i
laughed a lot and i kind of thought i
thought i would get my
my got some of my news from him turns
out he's making jokes
on the fake media you know so like if
he's adding to it
you're absolutely right he adds to it
but if you think the fake media
is the real media then he is funny it's
it's so john oliver
is he's a sophist okay it's like
basically
he takes a couple things to guarantee
his argument is correct
good point so uh i'll give you an
example of how
you know you can criticize me for not
being good at what i do for sure if you
think i'm bad
i did a segment about a former democrat
who was charged with voter fraud
in that segment as soon as i wrapped up
the news on democrat voter fraud i
highlighted a story about a republican
who was also charged with voter fraud to
make sure i'm not trying to make it seem
like only democrats do this the
republican was charged as well
however the stories were very very
different the democrat was actually
ballot stuffing the republican voted
with like a bad address so but i did
look up voter fraud and i made sure i
was like
i saw the story about the democrat i'm
like i'm not just going to do the
democrat i got to make sure i'd do some
search and sure enough we could go
republican as well i highlighted them
both i want to make sure
that i'm doing my best to be like am i
getting this right
i don't always get it right sometimes i
miss things okay but often i trace the
source of the stories to figure out
what's really going on
i can show you right here with this
story with this man garrett
the double standard is obvious they're
lying to you the media is lying to you
the activists are lying to you
this this guy's sean look look at man i
mean come on unarmed
v nonviolent please donate and here's
the photo of the guy with the gun
yep it's it's it's mind-blowing and 51
000 shares later i tell you
too many people on the left get their
news from memes i wonder how much money
he made
from that one post that one fake man lie
that he posted this is profitable this
is where we're at
two people arrested after gunshots ring
out near portland protest site
they found uh look at this these are the
molotovs and the mason jars
this is the the loaded magazines i don't
know what the
red paint is supposed to be i don't know
if somebody knows what that's for is it
like a
commie thing i have no idea i mean
probably like you know
make them think they're cool or like
some sort of blood
a lot of people were complaining about
like well how was it wet well it was in
a bag with molotov cocktails it was like
a paint thinner
that was wet the the you could see that
the the paint is still wet
and they were like they were trying to
trying to talk about it right but it's
like if you think about it a molotov
cocktail i don't know what they were
using as the flammable
liquid that was in there but most
alcoholic
things will thin paint so it makes i
mean i imagine there's a gas
yeah that's what they do they go to gas
stations and then they make sense
and so here you have the current state
of things yet
nadler's going to say the riding in
portland's a myth that's crazy
that that someone in in congress is is
he a congressman
yeah congress yeah doesn't matter anyone
of that
you know standpoint in the government
thinks that it's
a lie boldly saying it with a smirk on
his face and then waddle away and get in
the car
the guy's like oh man we're gonna get in
trouble for you saying that get in the
car
old man that's what it felt like you see
and you know what you don't miss like
this is why in the car get in the car
stop talking if you guys aren't familiar
with flecco's talks
f-l-e-c-c-a-s flekas he does a great job
because he's very polite to everybody i
lo i love watching his videos he'll walk
up to like some regular he's he'll wear
like a
a uh what is it what is like these
highlighter vests or whatever what are
they called
uh reflective reflective vest there you
go he'll walk up to people and he has
like an oatmeal spoon
yeah like a phone attached to it i love
it and he just very calmly like he did
this one segment that i was it was
fantastic
it was called trump is not that bad and
he walked into people and he goes
do you think trump is bad and they're
like yeah but he's not that bad right
and then most people are like yeah i
guess it's not that bad that's it that's
it
that's all the segment was but that's
funny but it's true it's like you look
how the media frames everything trump
does
it's like there was there was msnbc had
a woman on who claimed that trump was
talking about exterminating latinos
what yeah i kid you not and it's like
any re
any person who's like brain is on is
going
what yeah no way that happened dude no
way
i hear stories about democrats all the
time and i go no way
like there was that viral tweet from aoc
where she like she was claiming
people were claiming she tweeted we
should keep our businesses shut down
longer
when i heard that i said no way dude
there's no way
and it's like some things and that was a
clever one because it almost sounds
plausible
i know yeah i saw that i saw that tweet
it's been i still see it floating around
you'll tag me on it all the time not
really real she says a lot of crazy
things though
that's i haven't i can't confirm i can't
confirm it
we got it we gotta we thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you